foreign
ERS podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims we begin in the name of Allah
and we welcome you all to the Stream
how you guys doing today
no not mutually exclusive boy
I'm doing good doing good alhamdulillah
I think the viewers are doing amazing
we got brother Hassan here says the
bearded goatsikum
um
foreign
how's everybody's Ramadan been so far
alhamdulillah it's actually crazy how
fast it's been
um how fast everything went by man this
is what one two more days of fasting
it's crazy bro this was the first animal
done ever
you know he said that the day of
judgment will not happen until I'm
paraphrasing but he said that the hour
will not come until
he says something along the lines of uh
a year is like a month a month is like a
week a week is like a day and a day is
like an hour
and an hour is like the like something
he said something along the lines of
like the flicker of a candle or
something like that you know that's how
it feels man subhanallah yeah this
Ramadan has felt like it's only been a
week long
may Allah accept it from us regardless
and um allow us to meet the next Ramadan
inshallah
Dunya is running like flash yeah 100 on
the day of judgment we're gonna rise
after 80 you know 100 years of being
this Earth and we're going to say we've
only been alive you know a day or a part
of a day or something like that you know
that's how fast
this life goes by
subhanallah you know what's crazy bro
all these things going on with the whole
Matt Walsh and then the whole Chris
Tyson controversy before we go in to
these juicy topics I didn't want to ask
both of you what is one thing you guys
have learned this Ramadan and reflected
on
just gonna ask you guys the same thing
I'm the love bro I'll go first then
the one thing I learned this Ramadan is
gratitude is everything bro as soon as
we start getting caught in the cycle of
ingratitude
focusing on what we don't have instead
of being blessed and appreciative of
what we do have
the buttock is going to stop coming
because Allah says if you're grateful I
will increase you
now compare this to somebody that's
grateful even if they're not up
but they're mindful of all the blessings
they have in their life bro
and I think that me and Angel and Rami
at this this one realization and then it
was affirmed by the stream we had with
wahab where he was talking about and how
it's in our nature to lose sight of you
know gratitude and the blessings of
Allah gives us but may Allah allow us to
constantly keep this gratitude bro at
the Forefront of our minds I mean I'm in
Europe Allah I mean beautiful reminder
Roberto my reminder or what I reflected
on
is sincerity
um
that he's not commanded us except to
worship Him and to do so sincerely you
know with false sincerity and also not
half doing things you know taking things
seriously I mentioned this Hadith before
on another stream I want to mention
again today the prophet peace upon him
he said
the Allah has prescribed excellence in
everything and then later in the hadithi
goes on to say if you have to off
somebody
or off something they do it in the best
manner even something like that there's
a proper way to do it and if you have to
slaughter like Halal Slaughter then do
it in the proper manner and he says let
one of you sharpen your knife so the
animal spared from suffering and it
really taught me that sometimes when
things are not done excellently people
suffer
yeah
100 that's beautiful bro I never thought
of it like this
bro how about you man drop some gems for
us inshallah oh man okay so
what what fire was saying about the
whole uh being grateful thing definitely
100 because I was there with him when we
were realizing this together
um but the biggest thing that I've been
realizing this from a dumb man is
basically what Allah says in the Quran
where he says that this is all a test
basically
the everything is a test and he's trying
to see something distinguish like who
are the real Believers from the
Hypocrites from the ones that are they
say they believe but then when they test
it they you can tell clearly like they
don't really believe
you know and then he talks more into uh
the different stages right when you have
nothing and when you're poor when you
have scarcity and when you have
everything when you have abundance when
you're rich and it's like everything
that he's saying in the Quran is just
it's a hundred percent the truth but
it's crazy that like we know it we read
it
we think we understand it and it's not
till now that it hits you where it's
like yeah when you have nothing when you
have nothing
Allah is literally testing you to see
are you going to be stingy
you have twenty dollars in your pocket
are you going to be stingy with that
twenty dollars thinking that you have no
more money that you have to like use
this money for for what you need to use
it for because you don't have any other
money
or are you going to
give silicone you're going to give
freely and help those that are actually
in more need than you and then when you
have everything
are you going to be extravagant
or are you going to be modest and
reserved you know are you not going to
be like outlandish and just spending way
too much with this money you know it's
always a test every single thing that's
going on is a test so every single state
whether it's good whether it's bad even
that's a test every blessing Every curse
a test
like bro it's like let's say you're with
your wife and like you're also arguing
with something like this
even that's a test yeah so why if you
like bro and I say this man because it's
like I'm understanding it now it's you
know being in this Ramadan but like
before I didn't I can't say I fully
internalized like inside but like
if something like this is happening and
I understand that it's a test
why would I be moved by
why would it trigger me why would it
make me act in a certain way if anything
it's like okay I understand it's a test
yeah you know things might not be great
right now but it's only a matter of time
before
it swings full force into the other
direction it's like a pendulum it goes
into One Direction just keeps going like
this and this is a story this beautiful
story that I heard before was Muslim
that it was uh about this guy and I'm
just gonna butcher the hell out of the
story so please don't take my word for
it but this guy he had um a son
and his uh his son was going to go off
to the the Army he was being drafted and
everyone in the village was like oh like
it's it's such a shame that your son is
being drafted like you're not going to
be with him anymore and he's like maybe
and then like the next day his son ended
up falling off the horse and injuring
his uh I think his elbow or his knee so
he ended up not being able to go to the
Army
and then everyone in the village is like
oh isn't it amazing like your son is now
here with you like you can stay with him
he doesn't have to go to the Army and he
said the same thing maybe
and then they were saying something like
I think the next day his horse like ran
off and they're like oh man it's such a
shame that like now you don't have your
horse and all that stuff and he's like
oh maybe and then like the next day it
just bro like it's it's again it's a
pendulum it goes really good
really bad really good really bad but if
when we take it a step further we
understand that we're being tested every
single swing of the pendulum we are
being tested and subhanallah I've been
realizing that more and more this
Ramadan that's a beautiful reminder man
that's a really beautiful reminder I
think it really actually ties into the
topic today because it has a lot to do
with the decisions that Allah makes you
know you make decisions I make decisions
our decisions are never perfect man our
decisions are always flawed
but Allah is perfect he has infinite
knowledge and wisdom
and Allah doesn't make a decision that's
not perfect that's not the best
Allah only chooses what's the best so
anything no matter how difficult or how
easy it is is actually perfect for you
think about that it's actually perfect
for you because it's the perfect level
of testing for you to not completely
crumble unless you yourself don't you
know want to accept that test and go
through it in the way that Allah has
told us we should so and this goes down
to also biological level this goes down
to a a sexual orientation level this
goes down to who we are as individuals
Allah created us in a very specific way
and for a very specific purpose
and I think there's tremendous Beauty in
that because without Allah we would be
nothing
and if we were just a part of some
evolutionary process without God then we
are purposeless beings living
purposeless lives being meaningless
people
in a meaningless world and that's very
shallow and that's very sad
mommy bro
Allah don't think I didn't notice that
Segway bro
you're setting it up for the reaction
video I know you are I'm getting there
yeah because you're right bro we were
designed in a specific way and it
doesn't mean that we are discriminatory
for any of these tactics and words that
they use but it just generally means
that if everybody has their right to
believe what they want to believe and to
see the world the way that they want to
see it then why is it a problem if we
are antithetical to the status quo
and if we have our own values and
beliefs for us Muslims yeah 100 and what
happened to you know agreeing to
disagree we're not no one's coming out
against us we're not going out against
anyone and it's not about any one
individual it's about a deeper message
some people have some different deeper
message against Islam or whatever and
they they have their talking points
about Islam to get to that point we're
happy to converse with them we've done
it many times before we'll do it many
times in the future inshallah we also
have talking points against certain
movements in the west liberalism and
everything that stems from it because we
fundamentally disagree on things and
that's okay that's normal even
islamically there is room for debates
with even you know Jews Christians
atheists of any group to be honest
and with that being said speaking of the
base we actually have a debate right
here not between a Muslim and a member
of the
um that the the
game the LG LG TV Community but Matt
Walsh and the LGBT community or LG TV
Party come on bro all right
letters man today today
um anytime we want to refer to somebody
that has changed from one thing to
another
you just call them the tea gang bro okay
all right okay bring it up let's bring
up the video inshallah Bismillah
how would you define a woman because
you've asked other uh people up here to
Define how we would Define a woman how
would you define a woman Mr Walsh uh an
adult human female
whoa and Mr walls did you just assume
his gender
[Music]
and also I'm sorry let's pause they're
clapping
for that for the basic truth basic
biology excuse me Professor what's one
plus one
two
yeah buddy come on man
the bar is so low bro
[Applause]
don't trans people how doesn't a
transgender woman fit that definition
they're not female they they have they
have
you said that you are a biological male
correct I said I'm transgender
um I might be in her sex for all we know
about almost as many people in the world
are transgender as intersex and well a
lot of people don't know look at the guy
in the back behind the trends I mean the
T
just look at them bro look how confused
he looks what was that statement they
just said something like let's rewind it
the world are transgender as intersex
and well a lot of people don't know
well but that's a different conversation
intersex that's a genetic anomaly that's
a medical condition so that that's a
completely different conversation it's
also not a that's not a third gender
that's just a that's a genetic anomaly
that occurs within the sex binary of
male and female
um
a
so what you're saying is that a
quote-unquote trans woman is a female
by the definitions I'm familiar with yes
of course so how would you define female
through my training
in healthcare there are several
different categories for how we Define
sex people bring up chromosomes people
also bring up hormone levels people
bring up all sorts of other categories
lots of people don't fit neatly into a
gender binary even people we don't
consider to be intersex
it's a complicated Spectrum
yo he's getting worked up
oh no man do you have any thoughts so
far
no no nothing rummy yeah yeah I do have
a few things I want to say
so I I think what they mentioned in the
beginning is that most people in the
world are intersexual something like
that and this is such a a straw man most
people I think that's what they said
they could as much people as inter is T
wait what yeah they're saying as as the
amount of people that are inter like
born by by birth with both genitalia or
yeah uh non-functioning for either is
the same as the amount of people that
are trans that's basically what he said
I don't think he said most people are
interested I see I see yeah but even
that is is is fallacious the straw man
because
um I actually as Matt Walsh said these
are just offshoots from
pre-existing uh Sexes like the the most
most rare one I think uh is xxxy and
it's a chromosomal uh disorder that only
occurs in biological males right so
they're male but they have a you know a
disorder that's that but they're still
male they're still men and it's the same
and there's actually only 0.5 of the
population of the world
are born with like identifiable
confusing uh parts
so 0.5 percent
so it's not like anything
reminds me of yeah what it reminds me of
uh the self-fulfilling prophecy
oh yeah you guys know this
yeah what if he he came right in front
of you
and you called him a he and then he
looked at you and demanded that you call
him by his proper pronouns what would
you do
because I generally want to know bro
like pronouns is a big topic and perhaps
we can save this for after the actual
reaction video itself
but I did want to get both of you to
give me your insights or at least to the
viewers what we what you would do if
somebody demanded you in like a
workplace setting in a school setting
because you could lose your job
yeah before you answer that question
Rami or myself or even you fight once
I'll check y'all's phone real quick look
at our group message just to make sure
we're on the same page and then by all
means feel free to answer
um yeah I mean you want to go first
yeah inshallah so it actually made it
legal in Canada to misgender someone
call them yeah yeah you can actually
face fines in Canada
so I don't know I have to ask my Sheikh
about it I I can't answer from an
Islamic perspective from a non-islamic
perspective or even kind of from a
certain perspective you have to obey the
law of the land
um as long as it doesn't go against your
religion so if there's nothing Haram
about it then yeah you kind of have to
but if it is Haram then that's a
different story
um and I don't know it's a very delicate
discussion
um okay what about you on
I mean I've been
faced with uh situations like this where
I've talked to someone who
they've been claiming to be a different
gender or a different pronoun or fluid
gender fluid whatever that is
and
I can't really say much you know like in
the moment like I see that I'm just like
I'm like really
but it's like I just I kind of leave it
as it is like
I'm not gonna say anything in that
moment because what's he gonna do just
put them on the offense
what am I gonna do yeah what am I gonna
do shove shove truth into the mouse like
down their throats they're not ready for
that
no
yeah yeah
I agree bro I agree
yeah type let's get back to the video
onshaallah
let's put this up
it's not complicated but you also didn't
you also didn't Define so what is
what is a woman what is a female what do
these words mean
it's complicated and I know you're not
gonna like that answer but that's
because there are no simple answers in
human biology
just let me finish
you guys like to bring up High School
level biology classes a lot I get that a
lot but people who go on to more
complicated biology classes we'll talk
about sex as a spectrum it's not
it's not well biological researchers
would disagree with you well they're
full of the ones that would say that
there's
there are male gametes and female
gametes oh I had one I had one last
question
I said one I have one quick commit can
you come back for one second because
that's an important question you said
you're an EMT
okay if you're responding
you're responding to a health emergency
biological male
somebody with a penis
is uh is having a medical emergency and
they say to you
um I think I'm having a miscarriage
would you would you check them to see if
they're having a biscuit would you
consider that a possibility for them
oh
got him
no but
that's because some people don't have
body parts
doesn't mean they're not a woman okay
sounds like I just I wanna I wanna pause
for a second because I actually feel bad
you know it's difficult being in that
kind of position
um where you're like the only one in the
crowd who believes what you're saying or
saying something that goes against what
everyone else believes and they're all
like booing and oohing and clapping
against you and you could see it on
their face yeah it's a very it is a very
difficult position to be in even though
we disagree I mean we should still be
able to empathize with that and I think
anyone in the situation would feel kind
of succumbed by pressure
but based on what they said I think it's
important to even if we disagree
understand both sides so there's one
side which is the liberal side and
liberalism at a fundamental level is let
anyone do whatever they want as long as
they're not hurting anyone else so from
a liberal perspective if somebody wants
to identify as anything in the world
it's not harming anyone okay go for it
but the problem lies in now you're not
hurting on anyone else but are you
enforcing that
upon other people because what if I
identify as like the boss of everyone
does everyone have to listen to me
because everyone actually have to treat
me like their boss and believe I'm their
boss what if someone start what if
people start identifying as actual
animals and dogs will people be allowed
to be kept as pets
and put in cages and like is that
something that Society will actually
allow and accept and is that something
that people will account for uh in terms
of the legislation that's when it
becomes problematic so you have two
people or two sides you have the liberal
side who's like anyone do whatever they
want as long as they're not harming
anyone if the other side is who's saying
okay that's cool but there's a limit to
it uh based on things that are objective
and there are things that are objective
like human biology male and female and
that sex and gender are no different
because socially speaking people are
making the case that gender is separate
from sex and they can make that that
case because there's there's there's a
social realm to it right socially if
people want to introduce the third
gender and whatever they can do that on
a social level because this what comes
up in society doesn't have to be
objective you know people we or our
society loves orange
so everyone wears orange that's not
objective
you know that's what they do right so
they could do the same thing with gender
but they cannot say it's objective
sorry I don't know what just happened
boom bro yeah it's my job bro as soon as
you bring bring down the uh the low
camera angle bro
even that one cut off man
it'll be back in a second inshallah yeah
I like what you say room I like what you
say because you know you're showing a
lot of emotional intelligence in regards
to this uh individual
we'll put in that this individual who is
uh being put on the spotlight there
but listen at the end of the day like
yeah I mean this person put themselves
there this person knew what they were
getting into this person
clearly like was going against the
status quo and was trying to say this
isn't this and trying to go public and
trying to say these things where it's
like
if you get put on the spot because of
that I mean you should have been ready
for that you should have been ready to
accept that that wasn't a possibility
so I get it you know it's very Noble to
have emotional intelligence here but
it's also like
you can't
you can't hide the fact that like this
person knew what they were getting into
from the room yeah yeah 100 uh me
personally I just
I don't know I you can't really blame
anyone there's a whole crowd there of
people who are going to you know avoid
their opinion
um yeah and I can understand it bro I
can I can understand where you're coming
from because like bro
anyone any human will feel some type of
way they were put on the spot like that
and made to look this way in front of
everyone bro like that's not an easy
situation so I can feel that but I can
also understand that like look this
person knew what was coming
yeah
that's fair that's fair
um I still think that shouldn't stop
people from you know having having
respect and having Noble conversations
but I I understand you know Yanni this
is this is a real world
um not like that real world like you
know the Tates and stuff but
alhamdulillah this is reality and not
everything goes as as
like we said everything's perfect by the
will of Allah
imagine somebody from like the 1800s bro
time traveled came into this Dunya in
today's time saw this video bro
they would be completely caught off
guard
just unbelievable role that these are
things that are even disputed today yeah
yeah and that's that's a great point
because I mean throughout all of history
this has never occurred as far as I know
I'm not a story but to my knowledge this
has never occurred in human history and
they've always gone based on traditional
uh gender or sex roles for for men and
women males and females they never had
this idea yeah they had people who
actually castrated themselves in Unix
and that stuff but yeah there were some
men at the end of the day
um
uh and and they knew that so
it's it's it's finalized it is kind of
crazy how we've we've gotten to this
point now the question is what are we
basing this off of Are We basing off of
what people feel because I'm gonna feel
I have very strong feelings as well but
is that something you object you have to
accept as kind of an objective truth in
my reality and your reality or are we
basing it in things that are you and I
can also uh you know agree on and
identify together
that's the question and until we answer
that question as a society
uh we're going to keep having
disagreements and problems and the
biggest issue and the reason we're
talking about this because there is a
societal implication there is a societal
enforcing of this this they're being
taught our kids are being taught this
stuff in school
I just I I saw recently that the the
number of
uh the population for for for T people
between the ages of 13 and 17 has
doubled in the last three years the
studies vary in their methods and stuff
so there is room to you know justify a
increase in numbers
but it doesn't justify doubling in
number you know and you know what it is
though yeah
it's the fact that the
medical practitioners
are
I don't want I want to like watch my
word in your [__] but the fact that
it's so open
right you have a kid maybe the kid has
just like this confusion maybe the
confusion is stemming from the fact that
they are seeing something
in person in school or just out on the
street or they're just seeing something
within the environment or maybe they're
just having these thoughts so they go to
the doctor they tell their parents tell
me this parents take them to the doctor
and then doctors saying hey hey it's
it's perfectly fine to have these
thoughts
it's perfectly fine you know what
let's put you on some
anabolic I was gonna say beta blockers
but it's not beta blockers it's a
puberty blockers let's put you on this
let's put you on hold we don't know what
gender you are it's okay it's okay let's
just let's put you on hold you know what
if you want to be a woman it's okay for
you
imagine this imagine that openness that
level of openness to a kid a kid who
doesn't know what the hell they are
doing
they don't even know what they're doing
a week from now
yeah you're gonna tell me that this kid
is going to know what gender they are so
it's like if you if you provide that
level of openness that level of
choice
to a kid which doesn't have the level of
maturity that the Consciousness the
awareness the capacity to be able to
fully comprehend what it is that they
are deciding and what they're doing
bro it's a no-brainer that you're going
to have the numbers doubling bro watch
watch the next year watch the next few
years triple quadruple 10 times
it's only gonna get worse yeah 100 and
they always try and back it up by saying
oh it it saves lives
it also it also takes lives actually it
actually it also costs lives because of
T regret there have been people who you
know off themselves because uh they
can't reverse what has been done to them
and this is something that's been
enforced by professionals and by their
parents by their loved ones and by
Society so they think it's okay and they
go down this the route and they they end
up regretting it and it's your fault
it's your fault it's not just their
fault it's yours because you enforced it
now something else I want to mention
is there have been no studies done on
the long-term effects of chemical
castration
these puberty blockers there has not
been any long-term studies done on it so
they're just giving it to kids
essentially and and mind you in Canada
without the consent of parents Canada
every day is becoming more and more of
as Jordan Peterson says the totalitarian
authoritarian rule and um you know as
Muslims we're not really for democracy
but even in living in a democratic
country it's this is not Democratic at
all why are these laws that so many
people are against being enforced upon
us we voted this person and why can't we
vote them out
we voted someone in that's putting these
laws in why can't we vote it out
it's so sad subhanallah and people just
turn a blind eye to it
this is not okay you know what there are
studies for the the self-deletion rate
posed up
in most cases is higher than pre-op
and this doesn't even talk about those
that don't self-delete
but they live their lives in misery bro
which is worse than self-deletion if you
talk about you know suffering and how
much
how much pain that they have to put
through yeah you know I think that's
what one of the biggest issues is right
is that people think that these things
these thoughts that they're having in
the head are going to last for the rest
of their life
was like What if you were to just give
yourself
x amount of time like maybe 10 years 15
years 20 years
what if those thoughts completely run
their course and you no longer have them
you would have been looking back like
wow
thank God like I'm so grateful that I
didn't go and stop myself from going in
a period I'm so grateful that I didn't
chop my uh
member on Johnson now boy the schlong
I'm so grateful that I didn't uh go over
here and get implants on my chest
again we as humans we are constantly
changing
so imagine if these people who are
they're just so consumed that they can't
see past these thoughts that they're
experiencing they think that these
thoughts is like the end-all Beyond
everything it's it's it's all or nothing
there is no life after this like it's
gonna last for the rest of life no no
we're constantly changing
and if we're constantly changing that
means that in 10 to 15 years like you
really think you're going to be
struggling with the same thing like can
you say you're struggling with the same
thing now that you were struggling
before
maybe some people yes maybe some people
have like an addiction or something like
this but just like a random thought
maybe like a random thought that like
calls you disturbance
and most people can't say this but like
I think it was actually
confirmed that every 10 years
all the cells within our body
are completely new
they've completely changed so
essentially you're a completely new
person
10 years ago Mondo bro and the same way
that they're purporting that sex is a
spectrum bro we know mental health and
mental illness is a spectrum too bro
there's many things that go on behind
the scenes in our mind and I think one
of the big issues today is there's an
over diagnosis of mental disorders a lot
of things are just transient feelings
bro
but you're telling me if I go and I
express my transient feelings to my
physician they're going to give me
medications bro for life and they're
going to tell me you have this condition
this disorder bro
this does not happen a thousand years
ago two thousand years ago three
thousand years ago that was called a bad
day
yeah and keep it very simple all right
keep it very simple mental this order so
in the first word mental it means it's
up here it's in your head
now this order what's the order the
order is basically
a way of thinking a way of being
that doesn't create this ease for you
split the word disease this ease you're
not at ease you have thoughts in your
head that make you not at ease that is a
mental disorder that is all it is
it's very simple man it's very simple
I have one more thing just a rhetorical
question to ask why can't kids you know
get married or decide who they want to
be with the rest of Life at the age of
13 14. why is that not you know socially
or or legislatively in some cases
acceptable but it's okay for them to
completely change their
um Anatomy
the reason is bro we live in a agenda
bro where they don't want people to have
kids
and anything that promotes Family Values
is wanting to have kids wrong this type
of stuff is anti-family values bro
yeah it's a rhetorical question bro it
means that there's uh no answer my forte
is answering rhetorical questions bro
yeah yeah
[Music]
oh react says I feel like I'm in the
Twilight Zone look at how we have to
tiptoe around speaking the truth that
says all if your kids are in public
school instead of in Islamic school then
don't get mad when you lose them to
shaitaan
um oh boy I saw a video very recently
um and I won't name who it is or what
the video was about they basically said
the same thing it's like you know you
send your kids off in some Islamic
schools by the way you think they're
Islamic and they end up not being
Islamic so you send them to these
schools and you're like wow I wonder why
my my young man is now saying he's a
woman and all this stuff it's it's
because you you neglected them for so
many years and put them basically in the
public sphere to be taught whatever the
public is going to feed them
this is the West
this is the West all right it's only
getting worse so if y'all live in the
west y'all should start you know
thinking about this
praying and really considering getting
out of the West there's a before with
Muslim this is one song that I have
heard where it said that
people come to the west to live in the
west but they spend so much time here
that it's like they don't even
they don't even consider like leaving
because they think they're part of the
system they think they can change the
system the system is not going to change
you're not going to change the system
the only way that you can change
anything is by leaving the system
and how do you leave the system and you
leave the West you go somewhere else
there's many places in this world man
and Allah said it best hey hey man Allah
say the best in the Quran he said
was this world not sufficient enough
large enough for you to find another
place to live definitely butcher that
but you know 100
and I genuinely think bro when it comes
to specific things like this LG TV
Electronics movement you got the t-gang
all this cognitive disciplines bro
people are confused and a big reason
behind this is watching Haram videos bro
you know many people don't know that
when you watch Haram videos it almost
plants seeds that weren't there before
bro
because you're looking at your same sex
you're looking at another man as a man
being intimate with a woman or stuck for
Allah
and when you condition yourself to be
aroused to that it's only a matter of
time bro you're this close bro
before you start experimenting and
entertaining different thoughts and
maybe even actions bro and this brings
us to our sponsor of this video
alhamdulillah The ummah Academy go in
boy
hey amen
he's struggling with pornography Edition
or any sexual prediction for this matter
what the hell are you doing
it is no time to be going back and forth
in the same place over and over again if
you're in the same place that you were
several years back bro you gotta take a
step man take a step back ask yourself
why are you still in the same place
after you answer that head over to uh
our website the omo academy inshallah
and sign up be a part of it
it's 100 money back guaranteed the first
month if you find that it's not for you
but it provides you everything provides
you a three-month course Where You Are
being guided every single day for you to
get over this Edition and you will have
access to a whole community of Brothers
who are also going through the same
thing
and a whole bunch of other good stuff so
by all means if this is if this is for
you
click the link in the description box
down below if it's not for you share it
with someone who it is for get some
Azure it's it's almost there
inshallah that's what it is bro and to
this this lovely beautiful Habibi over
here if you could do better than do
better bro if not keep it moving come on
now the
we've established there are some people
who in principle can get pregnant
and there are some people who can't
so there's two categories otherwise
known as binary lots of women can't get
pregnant either
yeah but they're still of the nature to
get pregnant the only reason they can't
get pregnant yes but truth matters right
it does that's what I'm trying to
explain to you
truth matters and they can't get
pregnant that's the truth so how are
they still a woman
because they are
for for this for the same reason for the
for the same reason that I that I can
rightly say that human beings have two
legs and if a person is born with only
one leg that doesn't call into question
the statement that human beings have two
legs okay a person being born with one
leg doesn't mean that now legs are on a
spectrum and we can't say
we can't say anything at all about how
many legs a person has who knows they
could have they could be a centipede you
know they could have they could have a
hundred likes
no we know human beings have two legs if
a human is born without two legs
something went wrong they were supposed
to have that second leg something went
wrong if you if you if you meet a person
on the street only has one leg maybe
maybe they had an accident maybe they
were in war maybe maybe some you know
maybe they were in a car accident maybe
they had cancer a leg was cut off but
you know that something went wrong
because of the by their nature they're
supposed to have two legs same thing for
a woman a woman by her nature can get
pregnant a man by his nature never can
so if you meet a woman of child bearing
age saying she's 28 years old and she
can't get pregnant you know
automatically that something has gone
wrong and she can go to the doctor and
find out what that thing is even if they
can't fix it so that proves that women
by their nature can get pregnant because
the simple fact that she can't shows you
that there is something wrong this is
what is known as the exception that
proves the rule whereas if a male with a
penis can't get pregnant no doctor on
Earth is going to run tests to see
what's wrong with him
because they already know it's that he's
a male and there's only male and female
those who get pregnant those who can't
so all right that's it
[Music]
all right
very interesting and I think a very
fitting end to the conversation it's
very clear-cut it's very solid and it's
based in reality again one person's
coming from a liberal perspective of let
everyone do what they want if they want
to define a woman this way let them do
it another person is going by not just
the book or the textbook but buy
something that is objectively verifiable
in reality I like the example he gave of
human beings have two legs it's so sad
that we have to result to such basic
examples and basic analogies to deduce
very simple
basic points
of human nature things that have been
universally accepted
forever literally as long as humans have
existed
but regardless it was a very good point
any thoughts
is quite as possible bro yeah you tend
to do that
this far is getting to me bro
I don't even know how we're gonna do Mr
Beast
don't be weak man come on what's wrong
with you the fasting is nothing bro
people used to fasten the 1400 years ago
in the desert they used to travel and do
all these crazy things man come on man
probably the sleep deprivation bro
I'll make it easy for you let's do it
let's do it let's let's do the Mr Beast
as soon as we've done this inshallah so
I mean listen it's not about any one
individual nobody should be insulting
anybody that's not going to get anywhere
we should just stick to the concepts and
the ideas and the ideologies and deal
with things pardon me deal things on an
ideological level there's an ideological
war happening right now Wars are not
always physical sometimes they're
ideological
and you have to deal with the
ideological level or on the ideological
playing field so
what's I'm not going to feel myself but
with what I mentioned before with the
liberalism
and I'm not going to say being
conservative so I'm going to talk about
I'm going to talk about Islam because
I'm not talking about the liberal party
I'm talking about the the ideology that
both liberals and conservatives have
which is liberalism
this is this ideology was founded
before like America
it's something that or maybe at around
the same time in like the 1700s and it's
the idea that everyone should be able to
do what they want and Islam came 1400
years ago and they said humans need to
live by the rule of God not the way the
church did it because they were men
making it up
but God decides in Men in force
I'll say it again God decides in men
enforce and by men I mean men and women
you know human beings enforce the law
and until we live in the way that God
has designed us to live and we're not
going to be happy Allah says
he says those who believe
and whose hearts are content with the
remembrance of God indeed with the
remembrance of God the hearts find ease
with the hearts find contentment and
this is the very simple thing this there
are studies done on this people who
believe in God are happier people who
don't believe in God are more depressed
more sad depression rates are going up
as our society is becoming more Godless
it's very clear the studies in the the
data show this
so come back to God you'll come back to
contentment and happiness going from
Guardian further further down straight
down the path of sadness and depression
so again it's not about anyone
individual but the general ideas so when
I bring up the situation we're not here
to discuss any person but as a person
who's involved in the situation uh on a
big playing field that they are on this
has to be discussed so I'm going to
quickly
pull it up here inshallah
there was a one
one hell of a disclaimer bro
yeah gotta make it clear some people
need to hear it two three times you know
so
Chris Tyson Chris Tyson is the person
who works for or with Mr Beast on his
channel he probably all will recognize
him if you watch Mr Beast and what you
don't know is on 2017 he put out a
series of tweets now again yes this is
in 2017 so years ago but I don't think
he has been on the public record
apologizing to the Muslim Community or
attracting these egregious statements
that he made so first one here you could
see an event that occurred a very
catastrophic event uh it was very very
heartbreaking
and he for some reason feels it's fit to
post that you know don't say you love
the anime if you haven't read the Manga
inciting that oh it's a slam that did
this not political Warfare not the wars
that were waged in the Middle East by
the West
not hateful spiteful ideology that's
backed by political reasons not not
religious ones but yes let's just throw
it down to religion
next we have
him tweeting about what happened at the
Ariana Grande concert for years ago
saying why the bleep do we even take
Islam serious
it's an old backwards religion that
hates anything different and treats
women like bleep why
do people still accept it so in a tweet
this is funny in a tweet where he's
saying Islam doesn't accept anything
he's completely rejecting all of Islam
and all of the Muslims a very hateful
tweet to fight a hateful religion what
is this
what is this
and I don't even want to talk about the
fact that he has a clear misconception
of Islam he's just playing on the same
talking points that people have been
throwing
but what I really want to mention is
let me pull up one more time
this
someone put out a video about him
uh about about Chris becoming uh a woman
now
identifying as a woman and saying it's
going to be a problem for Mr Beast and
this is what Mr Beast replied this is
getting absurd Chris is in my nightmare
he's my friend and things are fine all
this tea phobia is starting to piss me
off
so how come
this tea phobia is pissing you off when
it comes to your friend
but his own is or their own islamophobia
in 2017 there is no reprimanding of that
you didn't say anything about that you
didn't call anyone out for that
unless you had a private discussion with
him I don't know
there was nothing done there was no
public apology
so why is you know why why is this this
discrepancy when there's someone you
work so closely with now
I think it's too much to push Mr Beast
for something he has like basically
nothing to do with because it's not him
it's not his life it's not his decision
so I think people need to back off on
him but I wanted to call this up because
I do think it's a discrepancy
um that he calls one kind of phobia out
and not the other one kind of
discrimination and not the other so I
think that is fair to hold him
accountable to everything else aside
from that I don't think people should
try and cancel Mr Beast they've been
trying to for so long I think he does a
lot of great work he's done so much more
than a lot a lot richer people have in
the past a lot more successful people
you know have done in the past he's
cured or helped cure a lot of blind
people
um through paying further medical
procedures he's done a lot of good and I
think people just want reasons to hate
on him and I think that's absolutely
absurd and messed up uh so I think we
should within what's reasonable
have this discussion about him and about
some of the claims that Chris has made
any questions
you know
no questions yeah inshallah starting
next week we'll have a call-in show
every Wednesday so stay tuned for that
Insha'Allah
um because it would be nice to get some
people on here to to chat respectively
about this topic yes yes
[Music]
um
I think it's best that we take a few
comments and end off the stream here
we've discussed a lot and made a lot of
points okay and we don't want to delve
too deep into anyone's personal life
that's true
yeah I like that you know you're not
insulting you're not making fun of
you're not doing anything like this you
just
you're calling me space you know you're
saying how it is yeah and it has to be
this way it has to be this way
especially in the day that we live in
and just
you get the picture bro yeah 100 100
speaking of calling a spade a spade one
last point I want to mention in light of
everything I mentioned before is
I think the worst part about liberalism
and liberal governments is they don't
care if you hurt yourself
that's why some of them allow like you
to you know like assisted sui
right they don't care about you you can
drink yourself until you're off from
this world
you can really they don't care
if you're in the middle of the street
with a knife or something yeah you got a
bunch of cops pointing their guns at you
some of them nice some of them are
meeting someone's trying to help you
some don't care they're just trying to
protect the public or whatever
that's why they pull their gun and not a
taser but you know with everything else
they don't care what you do to yourself
you can mess yourself up in every way to
Sunday and it doesn't they don't care as
long as you don't push religion onto
anyone literally as long as you don't
push religion or strict ideology onto
anyone they don't care so
that's something to keep in mind when
you're evaluating these liberal
ideologies
and uh your way of living and by the way
this is why Islam is a lot more Superior
and we can inshallah discuss that maybe
on next week's stream why Islam is
Superior in the western world
what a shame man
what a shame Chris
Miller genuinely got everyone bro I mean
I mean
and as a cherry on top like I always
mentioned Europe was a dying Nation yes
Europe was dying East and West you're at
war with each other they were dying and
the Islamic way saved them because they
translated all the Islamic books and
Islamic method and Islamic law and
Islamic philosophy and Islamic science
and math and and all this stuff
and they translate into their language
and they took it and they adopted it and
then they ended up progressing
themselves
the Age of Enlightenment would not have
existed without Islam we would be
technologically regressed by 300 years
if it wasn't for Islam we wouldn't have
MacBooks we'd have typewriters right now
if it wasn't for Islam you wouldn't be
seeing the stream you'd be you'd have to
come all the way from wherever you are
to come see us discuss in person hey but
it's a backwards religion man they don't
accept anything new so
okay I with all due respect I would love
to educate Chris and anyone who has that
mindset on what Islam actually believes
because you can't really blame them uh
unless they intentionally refuse to look
into Islam they're taught something uh
and he probably went through it himself
you know experiencing that day in
September
um he probably he was a probably a young
boy he experienced it himself and maybe
it was traumatized by it but what we
need Insha'Allah is to educate people
with love and compassion and be nice and
merciful until given a reason to be
harsh and then we can be harsh but
there's no reason right now inshallah so
I don't want to see anyone insulting
anybody and with that being said I think
inshallah we are safe to wrap up what do
you guys say
all right all right and then the colors
colors have you guys made it this far
by all means by all means just stay
tuned we got some good stuff coming out
with this calling show we have a channel
refresh like
expect big things
inshallah and let's end off as always
with a beautiful day for us and the
people
if you guys are ready
I should have started with this
from our tongues and expand our chest
and allow us to speak the truth may
Allah forgive us for our shortcomings
and our mess-ups and may Allah correct
us and allow us to correct ourselves may
Allah forgive us and grant us our Good
Deeds on the day of judgment may Allah
guide us and our loved ones and those
who we know and those who we don't know
the truth of Islam and allow it to
resonate nice and smoothly in the hearts
of everyone Allah I mean and at the end
of the day in life may Allah protect us
from the punishment of the Hereafter and
the grave and may Allah grant us the
highest levels of Jannah Allah I mean
um
and with that being said